Dankeschön.
Alles klar.
Ich wünsche Ihnen einen schönen guten Abend.
Mein Name ist Bulur.
Heute bin ich der Diensthabende Arzt auf dieser Station.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Gespräch durchführen.
Bevor wir über Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden sprechen,
brauche ich ein paar Informationen über Ihre persönlichen Daten.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Petra Klasing.
Wie heißen Sie bitte Ihre nach und Vornamen Bustebieren?
Der Vorname Petra.
Der Nachname Klasing.
K L A S I N G
Klasing.
Ich bin eine Frau.
Frau Klasing, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 57 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 18. Oktober 1967.
Wie groß sind Sie?
58. 1 Meter 66 und ich wiege 78 Kilo.
78 Kilo.
Ja.
Und Sie sind 1 Meter 66.
Groß und?
Ja.
78 Kilo schwer.
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Welche Beschwerden haben Sie aktuell?
Also ich habe seit 2 Tagen Bauchschmerzen.
Und die werden in den letzten Stunden stärker.
Und am Anfang waren die Schmerzen mehr so in der Mitte im Oberbauch.
Und sind jetzt aber auch im Rücken.
Und Sie sind auch zur linken Schulter.
Ja.
Linken Schulter.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Also jetzt, wie meinen Sie, wie stark?
Ja, auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10, wobei 1 sehr leichter sind.
Sehr stark in Schmerzen entspricht.
Ich würde sagen, jetzt sind Sie vielleicht bei 7.
Vor einigen Stunden waren Sie vielleicht noch bei 5.
Aber jetzt sind Sie bei 7.
Ja.
Ja, Frau Petra, Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie haben Oberbauchschmerzen.
Und jetzt die Schmerzen strahlen in den Rücken und in die Schulter.
Linken Schulter.
Ja, Linken Schulter.
Ja, Frau Klasing, das ist, ich denke, das ist eine Notfallstituation.
Ich muss Ihre Vitalparameter kontrollieren.
Ja, okay.
Was ist das, Vitalparameter?
Vitalparameter bedeutet Ihre Fieber, Herzfrequenz, Atemfrequenz und Blutdruckmessen.
Okay.
Und da war Stammzettelkunk.
Ja, gut.
Ja.
Sind Sie, ja, können wir weitergehen?
Okay.
Ja, Frau Klasing, Sie haben, ja, könnten Sie die Schmerzen bis Ende des Gesprächs durchführen
oder soll ich Ihnen...
Aushalten?
Ja, kann ich.
Ja.
Und wie können Sie beschreiben, wie sind die Schmerzen, sind sie eh durkend oder dumpf?
Schmerzen?
Sind eher dumpf und bohrend.
Aber ich kann nicht genau eine Stelle sagen, im Bauch, die am meisten weh tut.
Im Zwischen der ganze Bauchwee.
Ja.
Das hat sich ausgedehnt.
Ja, okay.
Und gibt es etwas bestimmte Auslöse für die Schmerzen?
Ist mir nicht bekannt.
Ja.
Ich möchte nicht sagen.
Ich habe keine Erklärung dafür.
Okay.
Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen lindert oder verstarrt?
Also, Linderung, so ein bisschen Linderung habe ich, wenn ich mich auf den Rücken lege
und wenn ich die Knie anziehe zum Körper.
Und hat da Sie einige Beschwerden für ja?
Nein, solch starken Schmerzen habe ich noch nie gehabt, da auch im Bauch.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich weiß nicht, ich muss stark schwitzen.
Das muss ich und ich fühle mich etwas warm, aber ich habe noch nicht gemessen.
Und Schüttefrost oder Nachschwein?
Schüttefrost nicht so richtig, aber ich habe in der Nacht doch stark geschwitzt.
Ja.
Okay.
Leiden Sie unter Erbrechen oder Übelkeit?
Ja, seit einigen Stunden habe ich mich über Übel und ich habe auch schon einige Male erbrochen.
Ja.
Wie sieht das Erbrochen aus?
Wie das Erbrochene aussieht, so schleimig, gelblich.
Und einmal?
Einwärfach, mehrere Male, bestimmt 4-5 Mal.
Ja, 5 Mal.
Haben Sie Blut in Ihren Erbrochen bemerkt?
Nein, Blut habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Ja, haben Sie Nachschwein?
Ich habe heute Nacht ziemlich stark geschwitzt in der letzten Nacht.
Ich glaube, ich habe das hingeverlustert, aber vielleicht auch mit den Schmerzen zusammen,
weil ich kaum geschlafen habe.
Okay, verstehe.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder mit einem Stuhlgang?
Nein, normalerweise nicht.
Ich kann das Wasser nicht so gut halten beim Husten, Lachen oder Niesen.
Meine Gynäkologin sagt, ja, das ist eine leichte Beckenboden-Schwäche.
Ich habe 3 Geburten gehabt und deswegen kann ich das Wasser nicht mehr so ganz gut halten.
Aber sonst habe ich keine Beschwerden, auch beim Stuhlgang nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Normalerweise ist der Appetit ganz gut, aber jetzt, seitdem ich die Bauchschmerzen habe,
ist der Appetit nicht gut.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Schlafen?
Normalerweise nicht, aber nur die letzte Nacht habe ich nicht geschlafen wegen der Schmerzen.
Sind Herr Trasen, Atemnot oder Brustengegefühl bei Ihnen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Probleme mit der Schlafen?
Nein, ich habe keine Probleme mit der Schlafen.
Haben Sie Husten?
Ich habe ein bisschen Husten, weil ich raucher.
Meine Familie sagt immer, du hast schon einen Raucherhusten.
Ich muss nicht immer Husten, aber schon einige Male am Tag.
Mit Auswurf?
Nein.
Nein?
Prognösten.
Okay.
Ja.
In der letzten Zeit waren Sie in Ausland?
Ich war im September, Oktober, war ich für zwei Wochen in Italien.
Sonst war ich nicht im Ausland.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, da achtet meine Hausärztin immer darauf, dass ich alle notwendigen Impfungen habe.
Ich glaube, ich bin vollständig geimpft.
Treiben Sie Sport, regelmäßig?
Nein, ich treibe keinen Sport.
Okay.
Waren Sie für diese Beschwerden beim Hausarzt?
Nein, die sind ja auch erst seit zwei Tagen die Beschwerden.
Ich hätte sonst gedacht, wenn das nicht besser wird,
dass ich vielleicht morgen oder übermorgen hingehe.
Aber die sind jetzt so schlimm geworden, aber ich habe gesagt,
ich muss jetzt hier, ich hier vorstellen in der Klinik.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Hauteverparbung, Ihre Körper, besonders in Bauch?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Okay.
Haben Sie irgendwelche chronische Vorerkrankungen?
Also ich muss seit einem Jahr nehme ich ein Medikament wegen meinem erhöhten Blutzucker.
Und ja, das nehme ich seit gut einem Jahr, das Medikament.
Und dann habe ich seit zehn Jahren ungefähr eine Unverträglichkeit auf Fruchtzucker.
Da hatte ich früher viel Bläh-Ehrungen und auch mal Durchfall.
Aber seitdem ich das weiß, halte ich eine gewisse Diät ein,
meide Fruchtzucker, halte ich gespeisen und damit geht es mir besser.
Ja, okay.
Und dann habe ich noch seit fünf Jahren,
es sind Gallensteine bei mir bekannt.
Und bisher hat mir keine Probleme gemacht.
Mein Hausärztin hat gesagt, wenn da aber Probleme auftreten,
dann muss man die Gallenblase entfernen.
Ja.
Aber Sie haben nicht operiert.
Bis jetzt noch nicht, nein.
Und Sie haben Blutzucker seit wann?
Seit einem Jahr.
Seit einem Jahr haben Sie eine wichtige Tabletten.
Tabletten.
Werche Tablette nehmen Sie da?
Die Tabletten heißen Metformin.
Metformin.
Kennen Sie die Dosierung?
Da steht 500 hinter.
Da nehme ich morgens eine Tablette und abends eine.
Ja.
Haben Sie noch andere Vorerkrankungen?
Nein. Andere Vorerkrankungen sind mir nicht bekannte.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, als Kind, da war ich, glaube ich, 11 Jahre alt.
Da wurde ich am Blindendam operiert.
Und dann hatte ich, da war ich, glaube ich, so 30 Jahre alt.
Da hatte ich einen Verkehrsunfall.
Und da hatte ich einen Oberschenkelbruch.
Auf der linken Seite, linker Oberschenkel.
Und der musste auch operiert werden.
War das Operation Komplikationlos?
Ja, das war alles gut.
Ich habe da heute auch kaum Beschwerden oder keine Beschwerden durchpasst.
Okay.
Und für die Klassen haben Sie, so haben Sie für diese Bauchschmerzen etwas eingenommen, ein Medikament?
Nein, habe ich bisher nicht gemacht.
Ich habe irgendwie gehört, man soll das möglichst nicht machen, wenn es eben geht.
Sonst würde der Arzt, der mich untersucht, dann nicht so ein gutes Bild haben davon.
Aber Sie haben ja gesagt, das dauert nicht so lange.
Ich kann es jetzt noch aushalten mit den Schmerzen.
Und nehmen Sie andere Medikamente ein?
Nein, sonst nehme ich keine Medikamente ein.
Und Sie haben schon gesagt, Frugsuche, Unverträglichkeit.
Und haben Sie Allergien?
Nein, Allergien sind mir nicht bekannt.
Und rauchen Sie, Frau Keiser?
Ja, ich rauche.
Deswegen habe ich auch mal diesen Husten, glaube ich.
Ja.
Ich rauche so 10 Zigaretten am Tag.
Seit 25 Jahren, seit der letzten Schwangerschaft, nach der letzten Schwangerschaft, habe ich angefangen zu rauchen.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum, aber ich habe es gemacht.
Also ich rauche jetzt 25 Jahre ungefähr 10 Zigaretten am Tag.
Ja.
Sie raken seit 25 Jahren 10 Zigaretten täglich.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke mal gerne ein Glas Wein, aber nicht jeden Tag.
Am Wochenende vielleicht auch mal 2 Glas Wein.
Pro Woche insgesamt vielleicht mal 5 Glas Wein.
Okay, das ist Routinefrage.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein, habe ich keine Erfahrung mit.
Ja, Frau Klosing, ich denke, Sie sind Wechseljahre.
Ja, ich gehe regelmäßig zu meiner Frauenärztin.
Und die Periode ist schon länger nicht mehr regelmäßig.
Und die Frauenärztin sagt, ja, das sind die Wechseljahre.
Aber ich habe eigentlich keine großen Probleme damit.
Ja, Sie haben eine große Probleme?
Keine, keine großen.
Keine, okay, alles war in Ordnung.
Sind in Ihrer Familie irgendwelche Kurze für Erkrankungen bekannt?
Ja, mein Vater, der ist 82 Jahre alt.
Der hat seit 5 Jahren hat er Blasenkrebs.
Er wurde da auch schon operiert und auch schon mal nachoperiert.
Und wird da regelmäßig kontrolliert beim Urologen.
Und er hat auch hohen Blutdruck, mein Vater.
Ist das nicht ein Klasik?
Die Mutter, die ist 79 Jahre alt.
Die hatte vor zwei Jahren einen Krebs am Gallengang, Gallengangskrebs.
Und da musste sie auch operiert werden.
Und hat sich von der Operation schlecht erholt.
Sie ist seitdem sehr schlapp.
Aber die Kontrollen auf den Krebs sind im Obendick, die sind ganz gut.
Aber die Operation hat sie sehr beeinträchtigt.
Ja, war das Operation Komplikation?
Es hat lange gedauert, bis sie wieder entlassen wurde aus dem Krankenhaus.
Aber sie ist seit der Operation geschwächt.
Ich habe hier noch eine Schwester, die ist 54 Jahre alt.
Die wurde vor zwei Jahren am Gallenblase operiert.
Sie hat wegen Steinen.
Dann wurde die Gallenblase entfernt.
Und ich habe noch einen Bruder, der ist 52 Jahre alt.
Der hat seit einem Jahr auch Zucker.
Und hohe Cholesterinwerte.
Ich verstehe.
Ihr Vater hat Blasenkrebs.
Und sie wurde eine Operation...
Ja, mein Vater wurde auch operiert.
Und noch mal nachoperiert, ein Jahr später.
Und dann bekam dann einige Zeit lang immer eine Flüssigkeit in die Blase hineingespritzt.
Man sagt, das war wie eine Art Hybotherapie.
Aber es geht ihm ganz gut.
Die Kontrollen waren jetzt in Ordnung.
Ja, okay, sehr gut.
Frau Petra, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Drei Kinder.
Sind die Kinder gesund?
Ja, sie sind gesund.
Was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin Sekretärin.
Frau Klasink, ich habe keine weitere Fragen.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, was kann das sein?
Solche starken Schmerzen kenne ich nicht.
Frau Petra, ich wege Ihnen eine Kanüle.
Dann geben Sie eine Schmerzmittel, damit Sie die Schmerzen nachlassen.
Okay.
Und was kann das sein?
Woher kommen die Schmerzen?
Frau Klasink, wir als Erster haben immer Dreischritte unter Diagnose-Stellen zu können.
Erst wenn Sie die Schmerzen unterdenken, dann nehme ich die Blut ab.
Dann werde ich Ihnen ein paar Labo- und Apparativen unterdenken.
Nach den Ergebnissen werde ich mit Ihnen wieder schiprieren.
Aber ich denke, wahrscheinlich haben Sie eine Bauchspeiserdürse-Entsündung.
Deshalb vielleicht die starken Schmerzen.
Dann wollen wir mal hoffen, dass Sie das bald herausfinden und mir dann auch helfen können.
Dann haben Sie jetzt zehn Minuten Zeit.
Mit der Prüfung sind es jetzt 20 Minuten.
Die Kollegen, die jetzt zugehört haben, das sind heute immerhin 36, 35, können gerne Fragen stellen,
wenn wir noch etwas vergessen haben.
Vielleicht ist irgendetwas noch nicht gefragt worden, was wichtig ist.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Können Sie flach liegen?
Ja, ich kann flach liegen, aber nicht so auf dem Bauch kann ich nicht liegen.
Ich liege lieber auf dem Rücken.
Und dann ziehe ich die Beine, die Knie etwas an zum Körper.
Aber Ihr Rückenlage ist am besten.
Wie viele Kissen werden Sie benutzen?
Ein Kissen.
Nicht mehr.
Vielen Dank.
Ich denke, die Patienten müssen jetzt noch keine Diagnose stellen.
Keine Verdachtdiagnose.
Die Patientin hat nur gefragt, was kann das sein?
Das können Sie ja eventuell differenzial diagnostisch erwähnen.
Jetzt brauchen Sie aber keine Diagnose stellen.
Gibt es noch Fragen, die eventuell wichtig sind?
Hat jemand noch eine Idee?
Wenn ich sicher bin, ob die Frage nach dem letzten Stuhlgang gestellt wurde?
Ich glaube nicht.
Es wurde allgemein gefragt, gibt es Beschwerden beim Wasserlassen
oder Stuhlgang?
Da habe ich glaube ich geantwortet, nein, bis auf,
dass Wasser nicht gut halten kann beim Husten.
Aber die Frage, wann war der letzte Stuhlgang,
ist bei akuten Abdominalschmerzen wichtig?
Die würde ich auf alle Fälle stellen.
Der letzte Stuhlgang war so vor 15, 16 Stunden.
Kurz bevor die Bauschmerzen,
die Bauschmerzen waren vor ungefähr 2 Tagen begannen,
15, 16 Stunden der letzte Stuhlgang.
Ich habe den Eindruck, normalerweise habe ich mindestens
alle 12 Stunden etwas Stuhlgang.
Das ist jetzt etwas weniger.
Aber ich habe ja auch wenig gegessen jetzt,
oder kaum das gegessen.
Stuhlgang ist normalerweise auch regelmäßig.
Vielleicht noch eine Ergänzungsfrage.
Wie oft müssen Sie in der Nacht auf Toilette,
auf Wasser lassen?
Ich habe es in der Regel 2-mal.
Das aber schon seit einigen Jahren, da hat sich nichts verändert.
Schönen guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich möchte Ihnen eine neue Patientin vorstellen.
Hätten Sie Zeit für mich?
Ja, habe ich.
Sie heißt Petra Glasig, ist 57 Jahre alt.
Sie ist 26 Jahre alt.
Sie ist 18,7 kg.
Die Patientin, die heute bei uns begannen,
seit 2 Tagen.
Das sind zwei Tage.
Ja, ich glaube, es sind zwei Tage.
Seit zwei Tagen, seit 5 Tagen,
seit 2 Tagen, seit 2 Tagen,
mit Ausstrahlung in den Rücken
und in die Schulter,
in den Rücken und in die linke Schulter vor.
Okay, Sie können sagen,
nach Dorsal, mit Ausstrahlung nach Dorsal,
Dorsal ist die Rückenpartie
und in die linke Scapular-Region.
Das wäre medizinisch vielleicht etwas klarer.
Haben die Schmerzen,
waren die von Anfang an im gesamten Abdomen
oder haben die irgendwo begonnen?
Ja, erst werden die Schmerzen im Mitte oder Bauch angefangen.
Haben wir vielleicht im Epigastrium?
Ja, in Epigastrium, im Mitte angefangen
und dann strahlen in den Schmerzen-Bauch aus.
Welche Intensität hat der Schmerz?
Schmerz ist jetzt bei 7 von 10
auf einer Skala.
Die Schmerz Intensität ist,
sind bei 7 von 10,
jetzt aber ein paar Stunden,
bei 5 von 10.
Also man kann sagen, der Schmerz hat in den letzten Stunden
zugenommen, an Intensität.
Ja.
Was können Sie noch berichten über Symptome
oder Begleitzymtome?
Ja, die Patienten haben Fieber,
38,2, Oralgemessen, Neusea und Emesis,
viermal, sie sieht Schleimung aus.
Sie können vielleicht folgendes sagen,
das macht einen guten Eindruck beim Oberarzt.
Bei den Anfangs aufgrund der Symptomatik habe ich die Vital-Parameter
gleich kontrolliert.
Unauffälliger Blutdruck,
SBO2 unauffällig, Sinusrhythmus um 90 pro Minute
und febrile Temperaturen bei 38,2 Oral.
Dann haben Sie den Überblick, der Oberarzt ist zufrieden,
ah, Vital-Parameter kontrolliert, sehr gut.
Und dann haben Sie auch das Fieber gemessen, die Temperatur.
Gut.
Und beim Rücklegen, verstärken sich die Schmerzen?
Nein, in Rückenlage verbessern Sie sich.
Ja.
Also in der Schmerz wird etwas besser durch Rückenlage,
auf dem Rückenliegend und wenn die Knie etwas angezogen.
Damit verbessern Sie sich etwas, aber nur etwas,
sonst ist der Schmerz kaum beeindruckbar.
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Und der Patient habe trockene Hüsten.
Die Patienten.
Ja, die Patienten habe trockene Hüsten.
Und ich muss sagen, dass die Patienten
Hypohydrosis habe.
Ja, Hypohydrosis, ja, okay.
Ja.
Gibt es Auffälligkeiten bei Stuhlgang oder Wasserlassen?
Ja, ich habe der Patienten gefragt,
aber es gibt keine Auffälligkeit.
Also der letzte Stuhlgang war ungefähr vor 15 Stunden.
Und die Patientin hat keine wesentlichen Auffälligkeiten
bei der Mixion Wasserlassen, bis auf eine wohl leichte Stressinkontinenz.
Sie hat ja berichtet, sie kann das Wasser nicht mehr richtig halten,
aber wahrscheinlich aufgrund einer Beckenboden Schwäche durch die Geburt.
Sie hat drei Geburt hinter sich und so wird das erklärt.
Aber sie ist keine Akutenbeschwerden.
Ja.
Die vegetative Anamnese ergab Schmerz.
Ja, Beschwerde bedingt in Appatence und Insomnia.
Okay.
Die Reiseanamnese ist unauffällig.
Die Patientin ist vollständig geübt.
Sie treibe nicht regelmäßig Sport.
Die Patientin habe seit einem Jahr Diabetes mellitus,
dagegen nehmen sie mit Formen 500 Milligramm zweimal täglich.
Und bei der Patientin wurde vor fünf Jahren Kolelithiasis festgestellt.
Ja.
Eine Operation würde ihr
empfunden.
Die Patientin wurde im Alter von
erst Jahren.
Gibt es noch andere chronische Erkrankungen?
Denken Sie daran an die
Fruchtzucker.
Ja.
Ich weiss nicht.
Aber sie...
Fruchtose.
Eine Fruchtose-Unverträglichkeit.
Ja, ja, ja.
Fruchtose unter.
Seit zehn Jahren.
Und sie äußert sich als Diare und Methodismus.
Ja, das war früher.
Und jetzt, seitdem sie eine Diät einhält, geht es besser.
Gut.
Operationen, hat die Patientin Operationen hinter sich?
Ja, zweimal Operation.
Bei der Patientin wurden vor fünf Jahren...
Ja, Entschuldigung.
Bei der Patientin wurde im Alter von
erst Jahren eine Epandemie dürft geführt.
Und die Patientin hatte im Alter von
30 Jahren eine Verkehrsmittelunfall gehabt.
Deswegen wurde sie bei ihrer Femurfracht...
Entschuldigung.
Deswegen wurde sie wegen der Femurfrachtur operiert.
Okay, gut.
Linkseitige Femurfrachtur.
Ja.
Und sie rauchte Sansekretin täglich seit 25 Jahren.
Und sie trinkte fünf Gläserwein am Wochen.
Pro Woche.
Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Sein Vater...
Ihr Vater?
Ja.
Ihr Vater wurde im Alter 82
wegen der Süstokarsinom.
Ja, also der Vater ist 82 Jahre alt.
Heute ist er 82.
Und vor fünf Jahren wurde er
wahrscheinlich Urotelkarsinom der Blase.
Oder ein Blasenkarsinom.
Ja, aber es wurde operiert.
Und gab es noch Nachbehandlungen?
Ja.
Und dann...
Ihr Vater
bekam eine Chemotherapie.
Ja, okay.
So kann man das erst mal beschreiben.
Hat der Vater noch andere chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja.
Ja, ihr Vater hat Arterialehypertoni.
Okay.
Und die Mutter?
Ja, ihre Mutter ist 99 Jahre alt.
Ja.
Sie wurde vor zwei Jahren wegen der Kolangio-Karsinom operiert.
Ja, okay.
Ja, ihre Schwester ist 14, 15 Jahre alt.
Sie...
Ja.
Er wurde vor zwei Jahren eine Kolangio-Karsinom.
Und er wurde wegen der Kolangio-Karsinom.
Okay, ja, gut.
Ja, der Bruder ist 52 Jahre alt.
Und er habe seit einem Jahr Diabetes-Militus.
Und Hyperlipidemis.
Ja, Hyperkollisterinemis, Hyperlipidemis.
Okay, gut.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Die anamnächtigen Angaben deuten am ersten auf eine
Polycystitis.
Polycystitis, ja.
Ja, Fieber schiebricht für eine Entstündung.
Okay.
Und als Differenzialdiagnose kommen Folgende in Betracht.
Und Acute pancreatitis und Myocardinfarkt.
Okay, gut.
Ich hätte diese Diagnose auch genannt, als Verdachtdiagnosen.
Ich hätte wahrscheinlich als erste Diagnose gedacht,
Verdacht auf Acute pancreatitis.
Ja, es spricht für die pancreatitis die Ausstrahlung nach Dorsal
und die Ausstrahlung in die linke Schulter.
Während bei der Cholizistitis oft eher die rechte Schulter ausstrahlt.
Und es ist nicht so sehr Dorsal, ist der Schmerz.
Aber es hängt wahrscheinlich mit den Gallensteinen zusammen,
die die Patientin hat.
Vielleicht hat ein Gallenstein die Papille verstopft
und es führt zu einer Begleitpankreatitis dabei.
Also jedenfalls ist da wahrscheinlich die Hauptursache ihrer Beschwerden zu suchen.
Deswegen hatte ich gesagt, der Schmerz strahlt nach Dorsal aus,
also in den Rücken nach Dorsal, ruhig sagen,
und in die linke Skapularregion.
Da strahlt der Schmerz hinaus.
Und das spricht schon dann mitunter für Pankreas.
Ja, ja.
Die Schmerzintensität mit sieben ist auch relativ hoch.
Wobei das immer subjektiv ist natürlich.
Differenzialdiagnostisch, Ulkos, Ventricoli, Drodeni natürlich.
Auch ein Myokatinfargt muss alter in Betracht gezogen werden.
Auch wenn es vielleicht nicht ganz so ist.
Aber wir wissen, dass die Symptomatik gerade bei Frauen manchmal
nicht so typisch ist, wie ich das seinerzeit noch gelernt habe.
Das hat sich verändert.
Das wissen sie besser als ich.
Aber ich würde sagen, ich bin mit ihrer Verdachtdiagnose
und den Differenzialdiagnosen einverstanden.
Ich bin auch einverstanden, wie Sie das gemacht haben.
Das haben Sie gut gemacht, ruhig und auch systematisch,
dass Sie im Anfang schnell gesagt haben,
Sie müssen jetzt erst einmal Ihre sogenannten Vitalwerte kontrollieren.
An die ich sehe, umsichtig.
Und das sollen Sie aber auch ruhig dann bei der Vorstellung der Patientin
beim Oberarzt sagen, dass Sie das gemacht haben.
Weil das ist wichtig, das macht auch einen guten Eindruck.
Sie haben gesehen, das ist eine akute Schmerzsymptomatik.
Und das kann eben auch durchaus auch was Kardiales sein.
Und da mache ich erst mal die Vitalparameter.
Das fand ich sehr gut.
Und ich denke, Sie haben auch die Fragen an die Patientin gut gestellt.
Achten Sie bitte immer ein bisschen drauf,
wenn es eine Frau ist, die Patientin.
Das ist meine Probleme.
Ja, ich weiß, das ist aber nicht Ihr Ereignis Problem.
Das ist das Problem von vielen.
Das ist so.
Ich bin mir immer wieder auf, aber dass Sie da vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen drauf achten.
Und Sie haben das auch in der Vorstellung sehr ruhig gemacht
und wenig die Hand ins Gesicht genommen.
Manchmal haben Sie die Hand dann kurz mal vor den Mund genommen,
möglichst nicht tun.
Aber das haben Sie wenig getan.
Also das ist eine kleine Kritik von mir.
Aber ansonsten konnte ich Sie auch gut verstehen.
Und ich bin sehr optimistisch, was die Prüfung in Stuttgart angeht.
Dankeschön.
Ich bin auch Kardiologin.
Ja.
Insofern denken Sie auch gleich an den Myokartinfarkt.
Ja, ja klar.
Ja klar.
Das ist so.
Ich hoffe, dass Sie dann demnächst auch in Ihrem Gebiet arbeiten können.
Ja, ich hoffe.
Und Sie sind im Raum Stuttgart oder weiter weg?
Ja, ich wohne im Vorzweichen in der Nähe Stuttgart.
Ja, das ist nicht weit weg.
Da gibt es ja verschiedene Kliniken, Sindelfingen und Böblingen.
Klinikum Sindelfingen, da ist mein Bruderchef gewesen,
der ist Kardiologe.
Ja.
Ja, ich möchte mit Ihnen kennenlernen.
Können Sie, vielleicht haben Sie ihn kennengelernt.
Aber er ist jetzt nicht mehr Chef, weil er ist jetzt inzwischen auch im höheren Alter.
Aber er arbeitet noch als Kardiologe, besonders die Ambulanz macht dann noch ein Sportmedizin.
Ja, gut.
Ja, dann wünsche ich Ihnen viel Erfolg, noch eine ruhige Vorbereitung
und grüßt Sie mir Baden-Württemberg.
Ja, und für die Kollegen, wir können gerne nächste Woche am Donnerstag uns wieder treffen um 18 Uhr
und dann wünsche ich allen einen schönen Abend und machen Sie es gut.
Tschüss.
Danke schön.
Danke.